heidelberg is smaller than i expected
nevertheless it's
it's just perfect for a young researcher
because you can reach everything in
in no time basically
you have the luxury of feeling like you
were on holidays
my name is agnes horwat i'm 28 years old
and i'm from romania i work here in
heidelberg at the interdisciplinary
center for scientific computing
i started learning german when i was
eight and in our books there were many
times lessons about heidelberg about the
castle about the university the very old
and beautiful university so i was
i was anxious to come here to visit and
i am super happy to have
also lived here for a couple of years
now
what usually happens is that someone
from an experimental
field comes to us and says okay i have
some really nice data
but i want to understand my data better
and this is something that is mainly
done within network analysis it's a
field that
takes its methods from statistics graph
theory statistical physics data mining
and tries to to explore these
relationships between different
a
objects
nice project of us
was in collaboration with the german
cancer research institute
where a group of system biologists had
done experiments on the effect of
several biomolecules and proteins in
especially lethal type of breast cancer
they had data we we came up with a
method with which
we could identify potential tumor
suppressors
networks of people are probably the most
interesting actually because
usually when we think about networks we
we do huge simplifications is there a
relationship or not and with people the
relationships are so different this is a
goldmine actually for a researcher
the more important my my networks at
work are you know and the more i neglect
my my personal network and i always try
to find a balance
so this is this is something you you
need to need to do find a balance
between your personal network personal
life and your work networks
you